most of the pet owners that are using
the product or using it for separation
anxiety
things like hip dysplasia and arthritis
mobility pain aging a lot of aging dogs
are using the product and then we have
some dogs that have epilepsy that use
the product with great success
some dogs with cancer that are also
using the product so it's a pretty wide
range of conditions that can be
addressed with CBD really successfully
Julianna karela is the owner of the San
francisco-based edibles company auntie
Dolores in 2013 she started up a new
company that makes dog treats containing
cannabidiol also known as CBD which
comes from marijuana free of THC there's
no other psychoactive ingredients in the
product so it's totally free of anything
that would get your dog high CBD has
become readily available in most states
with medical marijuana laws and its
effect on dogs is a positive yet little
noticed result of weakening drug
provision prior to 1996 the only way to
get CBD was on the black market it's not
explicitly banned but since it comes
from the marijuana plant no legitimate
business would touch it cannabis is a
Schedule one narcotic which means that
is how this information has been
strategically suppressed in my opinion I
really feel like the research is about
80 years behind where it should be the
research of CBD might have been hindered
by archaic drug laws but scientists and
medical professionals are making up for
lost time the 76 scientists currently
registered with the DEA for CBD research
purposes it seems as though the laws
might finally be loosening for the CBD
and for medical marijuana in general
we've had a tremendous amount of
feedback from customers a tremendous
amount saying how I mean from just it
being a subtle change to be very very
dramatic heidi hill is the owner of the
holistic hound pet store in Berkeley
California her store sells CBD dog
treats I describe holistic and as being
a health food store for dogs and cats
and dogs and cats right now I've been
surprised at how many people around here
know about it many of them have medical
marijuana cards and are already you know
using medical marijuana or CBDs for
themselves and so when they saw that we
had the treatable as they were they were
already on board because they already
know while the CBD tweets from treatable
are available worldwide federally CBD is
still illegal
which leaves companies that make the
palliative dog treats operate with some
legal uncertainty creating in that space
is very tricky
cannabis is still a Schedule one
narcotic so we still have all the
restrictions that we had before and
until that changes it's gonna look like
this for the time being it would be
great if they would be scheduled
cannabis as opposed to rescheduling it
it doesn't belong on the CSA list at all
in my opinion so once that happens then
the research that's supposed to have
been happening all this time will will
happen will start to happen here in this
country